der ebola ausbruch im kongo erreicht
eine neue entscheidende phase der worst
case ist jetzt bereits geschehen schon
kurz nach dem ausbruch hat die solche
bereits eine millionenstadt erreicht was
vor wenigen tagen noch befürchtet wurde
ist jetzt schon eingetreten der erste
infizierte ist jetzt im wan dakar
aufgetaucht damit bekommt die solche
eine deutlich schnellere dynamik als
noch vor vier jahren als sich wochenlang
auf dem land diese solche hielt was sind
jetzt die folgen im kongo was macht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und geht
jetzt alles viel schneller als noch vor
einigen jahren in westafrika krieg zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
heute hier vom swr aus mainz der worst
case ist eingetreten und das viel
schneller als befürchtet
zwar gibt es nur ein paar infiziert dem
kongo aber davon sind einige pflege also
personal das die solche an ganz viele
kontaktpersonen verbreiten kann auf dem
land halten sich die kontakte ja
meistens in grenzen aber in der stadt
sind einer solchen solche kaum grenzen
gesetzt und damit ist jetzt schon ein
einer sehr frühen phase
der schlimmste fall eingetreten ein
infizierter wurde in der millionenstadt
man dakar entdeckt vom ausbruch in
westafrika wissen wir ja wie
entscheidend einzelpersonen sein können
und dann zum super verbreiter werden
können und genau das kann jetzt hier
geschehen sein die stadt mit rund 1,2
millionen einwohnern bietet dabei den
idealen nährboden um eine solche schnell
zu verbreiten es gibt kaum elektrizität
und auch nur wenig sauberes wasser
die stadt liegt am ufer des kongo
flusses mit waren und personenverkehr in
die hauptstadt kinshasa
die menschen sind hier mobil und können
den erreger innerhalb von nur wenigen
stunden anders als im ländlichen raum im
ganzen kongo verbreiten
mit dem infizierten hat die solche laut
weltgesundheitsorganisation who eine
neue phase erreicht die neuen zahlen
sprechen von 42 infiziert von 23 toten
die kontaktpersonen werden auf 500 bis
4000 geschätzt zitat mit dem fall in
baden ist die situation äußerst ernst
und besorgniserregend geworden da die
krankheit erstmals eine stadt erreicht
hat so henry gray von ärzte ohne grenzen
ebner ist ein fieber das in rund der
hälfte der fälle zum tod führt das
beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine grippe
aber im weiteren verlauf fangen die
opfer an überall zu bluten und sterben
schließlich an multiplem organversagen
übertragen wird die krankheit meistens
von sogenannten reservoir würden
das sind wildtiere die gejagt und
gegessen werden durch die abholzung von
wäldern rücken menschen immer näher an
diese populationen heran und jagen dann
flughunde affen oder zum beispiel
stachelschweine und dieses buschfleisch
führt dann meistens zum ausbruch der
seuche im gegensatz zum ausbruch 2014
ist die weltgesundheitsorganisation aber
dieses mal deutlich schneller in aktion
getreten generaldirektors debré jesus
ist bereits vor ort und 4000 dosen des
über den berichtet hatten mit dem
kontaktpersonen geimpft werden sollen
die sind auch bereits im kongo trotzdem
ist der region
man muss sagen in panik in nigeria soll
ein für den 28 mai geplantes fußball
spiel der nationalmannschaft gegen die
nationalmannschaft des kongo abgesagt
werden ein solches großereignis mit nur
einem infizierten könnte eine
katastrophe auslösen
man ist also extrem vorsichtig und aber
auch sehr gut vorbereitet doch eines ist
dieses mal anders so früh wurde die
solche noch nie in eine millionenstadt
getragen ich hatte euch ja versprochen
euch auf dem laufenden zu halten
das mache ich auch weiterhin ihr wisst
ja dass das abo modell auf youtube nicht
so richtig funktioniert deshalb wenn ihr
also nichts vom ebola ausbruch zum thema
verpassen wollt und als erster
informiert werden wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer whatsapp und den anderen
messengern dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
um garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und zur begrüßung habe ich auch noch ein
kleines goodie und natürlich nicht das
abo mit der glocke vergessen und zur
sicherheit hier geht es war damit dafür
auch darauf klicken neuer ausbruch mit
der vorgeschichte dieses ausbruchs
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran